- I've heard about this
and I heard it sold out
and I want to know who you
killed to get this, honestly.
(light music)
- On Cyber Monday,
Kylie Jenner came out
with a line of lipsticks
that sold out in 30 seconds.
- And got resold on Ebay for
up to ten thousand dollars.
- We decided to try them out
to see if they live up to the hype.
- It's Ladylike and we're testing
Kylie Jenner's Lip Kit.
- We're going to be trying Candy K.
I'm surprised that Candy
isn't spelled with a K.
Line lips with liner,
fill in with liquid lipstick.
Remember that.
Kylie said it.
- Kylie, I need more
tips than just line lips.
- Also, how do you sharpen these things?
You guys see, this is plastic
so you can't sharpen it
and there's also no turn thing.
- Now we've got this
matte liquid lipstick.
You know what matte means?
It's going to dry the fuck out of my lips.
- That smells like a lipsmacker.
- I wouldn't say it's too
light but it's not my style.
- I look like a Bratz doll.
- I mean, it's a nice
demure color this one.
Am I doing it wrong?
I feel like I did it wrong.
- Okay, it's drying.
Okay, it's starting to
look a little better.
- Oh, it's getting darker.
- Wow, this stuff is dry.
- It's puckering my lips almost.
- Cool though.
Looks good.
That's all that matters.
- It's not a very lifelike color.
It's a little like wax figure.
- It makes me look like
an 18 year old billionaire
so that's all I care about.
(light music)
- Yeah, I'm feeling
like this is definitely
the color of my skin.
- See, now it looks dumb.
Does it look good?
I don't know what looks good anymore.
- They all smell so good.
- Goes on great.
Smells great.
Found a nice nude for my chocolate skin.
- As it sets in, the color gets better.
It's a weird sensation.
It's like a magic trick on my face
but I like it.
- I feel pretty cool in this.
I'm not going to lie.
- I guess there is a positive
to her wanting to be black,
creating this new lip for
black ladies like myself.
(light music)
True Brown K.
- They have Candy, Dolce
and then just Brown.
- I'm holding my breath while I do it.
I can't do it.
- There's no room for
error with this color.
- Mary J. Blige in the 90s.
True Brown K.
- Oh my God.
- Ooh, it's almost black
which I'm really into.
I like being the queen of
darkness as much as possible.
- I like it.
Ooh, I feel like an adult.
- It looks like I just got into
a chocolate cake, honestly.
- You can really see the lines inside.
- I want to kiss myself.
- I feel like I could date Tyga.
(light music)
- Kylie Lip Kit looks great
when I'm sad and pouty
but when I smile,
you can see the lines.
It's not for smiling, I don't think.
But as Kim says,
smiling gives you wrinkles
so don't even smile.
Why are you even doing that?
- I'm eating a burrito right now
and I really hope
that the Kylie lipstick
stays up to the challenge.
- I had an apple.
I had peanut butter.
I had popcorn.
I had water.
My lips are still on pretty tough.
- I've been sipping on this all afternoon
and there is no residue.
- I'm jealous.
Looks good, Candy girl.
- Annie said, it looks good from far away
and then up close, it looks like--
- The Sahara Desert.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, you
could see the cracks.
- Okay, I need Carmex.
- How was it?
- I actually got a lot of compliments.
- It looks good.
- Oh, thank you.
- I think the colors are cool.
- The three different colors
sort of work with a bunch
of different skin tones,
which is really cool.
- They are wrinkly though.
- I'm going to give Kylie this one.
- Yeah.
Got to give it to her.
- Kylie, one.
Resentment, zero.
- I would say if you can get online
and you can actually get the
lip kit as soon as they drop,
sure, pay 30 bucks for it
but I wouldn't go on Ebay and spend,
bid on lip kits for thousands of dollars.
No.
I wish that there was more
pencil in the lipliner.
- Yeah.
That is a valid question.
- It doesn't come with a sharpener, right?
- No.
I don't know,
we don't know how to sharpen it.